good morning Hank it's Monday of how to
week and today I am going to fulfill the
most common request we received and tell
you how to make a baby which as it
happens is one of my fields of expertise
as you can see I have several fields of
expertise ok so some people will tell
you that making a baby is a one-step
process particularly if you're a dude
but those people are wrong in fact it is
a seven step process step one before you
make a baby of your own you're gonna
want to check out a baby that someone
else has made from this experience you
will likely learn that one babies are
cute and two babies are monsters of
narcissism who believe that there has
never been another human being in the
history of the world and who also
believe deep down in their tiny little
baby souls that you exist solely for the
purpose of attending to their needs in
fact I would argue that whether you find
babies cute is not necessarily relevant
to whether you'll enjoy having a baby
step two okay say you go to bed at 11
p.m. set your alarm for midnight wake up
and listen to this for 20 minutes then
check you a.m. wake up listen to this
for 20 minutes and so on
24 hours a day 6 no breaks ok so having
done that you're now ready for step 3
there are several ways to take step 3
from test tubes to turkey basters but by
far the most common is to have sex
alright that was fun step 4 if you're a
woman it's time to give up sushi and
caffeine and alcohol and go-karts and
most of the other things that make life
worth living but the good news is that
now you get to vomit all the time or if
you're a dude you get to stand outside
the bathroom door listening to vomit and
thinking to yourself very quietly
because you know from experience that
the person you love the most in the
world can sometimes hear your thoughts
that person I love most in the world
sure was less cranky when she used to
drink coffee and not vomit so much step
5 if you are the person giving birth it
is time to do the hardest core thing you
will ever do in your entire life if you
are not the person giving birth this
would be a great time to say you're
doing awesome and then faint step 6 the
baby cries step 7 you cry which begins a
dramatic increase in the total number of
minutes people are crying inside of your
house and that in seven easy steps Hank
is how you make a baby at which point it
becomes socially inappropriate for you
to wear your zombie unicorn
even though you are still young at heart
nerdfighters are doing more how-to
videos this week so leave your
suggestions for what you'd like us to
teach you how to do in the comments Hank
I gotta go upstairs and do daddy stuff
but I will see you on Wednesday